morning Millennials Wow feels good to
say that again am i right Jax totally
I've been saying it for weeks rate my
friends with strangers how are you with
non-mining else I'm good I'm glad to
have you back sis thank you for holding
down the fort it is not an easy job just
Manning these chairs it was not an easy
job you know we do it for the love of
the toast it was an interesting meet
with a lot of interesting diverse
characters we strayed from our usual
suspects our usual cast of characters
how would you say it went I think it
went really well I think like who's my
favorite I just it was my favorite what
an honor to host with just such a legend
with a fellow host with a fellow host a
legend like an icon in the making it
really it didn't disappoint I was I was
really I really enjoyed it and then you
know obviously the snitch and Ben was a
nice addition we're great Penn's episode
was really funny we were just like being
so stupid and then class had been being
surveyed were just a different flavor
and I loved it whose Oh Jeffrey I was
like I thought Lumias and Jared they
were like a duo like Beyonce and jay-z
Louis and Jared yeah they were great and
like did you bury the hatchet there was
did you address gotcha
we addressed the hatchet also I'd never
met him before I didn't really want to
have a suit he was on so I didn't know
what the beep was and then when I was
thinking about it I was like okay so we
made a fact talk about Kelly Clarkson
like big deal not in this house you
don't first of all but in this house
we're we're all about taking chances
we've said some again we're just gonna
and we're gonna roast em on no we're not
roasting we let him back in for a second
chance but we have to make it clear why
we didn't like the joke one you can't
call girls fat too especially not guilt
a little sensitive like especially not
Kelly Clarkson I agree like there's we
only respect Haley Hardin and you know
as we always say there's a special place
in hell for boys who call girls fat I
guess we were just like those in glass
houses I agree we were being a little
sensitive and not critical and that's so
not like us I couldn't agree more cuz we
make fun of those who are so sensitive I
think I was just like wanting to start
drama you know you know me okay great
then so that and that's the real reason
we need a lot of dicks on this stage yep
and now we have the biggest one Jackie
we didn't do anything
April Fool's for you guys because it's
stupid because we're not in
ya know because we value your time like
we know you guys have busy lives some of
you may be at work some of you may be at
home breastfeeding your newborn child
I'm just waiting to take that airtime
like and take advantage of it because I
think people have that fun who do that
are stupid yeah and I can just see in
the room at work you know back in
February they're like ok team who has
the best idea for April Fool's and
everyone like spins their wheels trying
to think of something and then like they
pick the worst idea and that person
feels great and everyone else feels like
[ __ ]
and you know what I'm just not interest
on I couldn't I remember when I worked
for corporate America by back in the
summer they were like ok we need a
really great April Fool's prank and but
it can't be too crazy because we don't
want people to like get excited and it
can't be like you know this I'm like
right so I had thought about like two
things maybe I was gonna do on my
Instagram like one like me and Matt are
pregnant even though I was getting
blackout drunk two days ago when
everyone saw so like obviously not but
it almost looked like that's not a good
one because then it's like you get
people's hopes that's another
disappointing that's not true terrible
like bed Lara agree I mean I've never I
wish this through as well right so then
I was like okay maybe I'll like pretend
like I got a Netflix special but then
that's like sad cuz like I really want
one right exactly so it has to be
something that's unbelievably benign or
people will be relieved when they find
out it's not true and also like I
thought also they know already like it's
like right here foolin like I woke up
from a long text from Dana I'm like oh
it's so it's April first right um I had
like a good one for not a good actually
is a bad one but it was one for the
toast that was benign enough that we
were going to announce that we we're no
longer live streaming on YouTube no
longer gonna be a podcast that we were
gonna be exclusively on twitch on the
site ran that wouldn't have been good
just experiment to see how people would
react random enough and but in our bad
luck right another thing it's like if
you if you joke about things that you
actually want to happen it's like I have
three career goals in the next five
years and if I joke about them happening
they're not gonna come right so I say
them out loud yeah okay I'll say that
okay
pregnant special yep career goals baby's
content that's true look it's new yep
look special he's punching above his
weight these days be nice what does that
mean I think he's you know he's really
like
you can't call Kelly Clarkson fat you
can't call CEO I I really I know I've
been calling him fat but that wasn't me
like he's bringing home the bacon okay
sure Netflix special you know what
nothing no a special I would take Hulu I
would take Vudu at this point I would
take like pornhub okay that number to a
big-time media partner for the toast I'm
thinking really like a Hulu there I
think there would be the greatest
platform for us okay who's been bashing
Netflix you know as a platform and then
my third is one I don't want to say
because I think it's coming true
oh I oh right oh right that was like I
feel like that falls under one of the
other pillar know that has been my goal
for a long time it was like a five-year
goal and like it's happening into like I
can tell you soon later not on April
Fool's because yeah there's anything I'm
joking but everyone says to hunker down
for the rest of the day but you know
also I just I saw something crazy but
before you do I just want to just it's
back to April Fool's nobody's we're good
minds about goals okay you know what
because the toasters like really like
helps me understand like I say Oh mood
board and stuff like when you say your
goals or like you at least just like
formulate goals it makes it easier for
them to like happens you don't II mean
and then like I feel like I've never had
like actual like tangible goals be like
I want this to happen in five years but
now like in the past year I've really
like started to set goals for myself and
I feel like they have a better chance of
coming to you because now I have them
right you know if you don't have goals
they can't come true it's running like
the 11:11 wish and what why I started
wishing for tangible items like a Gucci
bag which really didn't start as a
materialistic thing it was like to see
if 11:11 was a real thing and on a
festive string it's like if you made a
birthday wish like I hope that in five
minutes I get something and if you got
it then birthday wishes are real and if
you don't then they're not April Fool's
what did I see what a few days ago
huda beauty posted that they were
launching fake eyelashes furred pets and
they were like if you're want like if
you want them like join our wait list
here and then I'm like I'm pretty sure
that's an April Fool's joke that they
launched they press that go early or
they're like starting early or they get
one asperity no because if you do it on
April 1st like no one will believe you
some able to do the point like right
okay so so I'm waiting for them oh no
that has to be that has to be password
that's like borderline like unethical
criminal but it's like
this isn't like a like Christmas where
there's a lead-up to April Fool's in
like the 25 days of April Fool's it's
like you get April Fool's you should say
your piece people will probably think
you're kidding because it's April Fool's
but that's what's healthy because if
it's like a little before a little after
it's a whole year before paul mark has
the 2013 days of april fools
by the way Olivia culpo was doing a huda
beauty it's hard to say who to beauty
because you want to say huda beauty
beauty beauty yeah like it cuz it's
opposite uses of the word the letter you
Hugh de beauté know who WT they're doing
a collab with Olivia culpo I know we're
gonna buy it um no because I don't wear
fake lashes oh is that what it is uh
yeah the lash business is money like we
gotta get into lashes I know but I just
said hey Luke I know but Lily lashes
yeah she's like a billionaire from
lashes good for her it wasn't she
already won oh yeah yeah it totally so
what's why you know so what else did we
need to recap we had Ben's birthday this
weekend which was just a jolly good time
we hosted at the Langham Hotel which did
you know used to be this attire didn't
know that I knew that because Olivia was
telling us at dinner where we went
before it was such a sorry like well she
used to work there she was right not
taking the employee entrance I was like
how does this relate to the story right
now special kind of person where's she I
think she gets it for me where she can
make anything about her you know and I
respect that no it was quite interesting
on though and then I was like suit I
like chickens the time right and then I
thought that's a weird name for us it
builds chicken satay well I put it out
into the universe last week on the toast
that I needed somehow planning Ben's
birthday party and it's amazing toaster
Michelle helped me out so thanks and it
was really good time I was actually 6:00
in the morning my thighs are so sore
like literally I cannot get out of bed
one time yesterday except to pee and it
ordered okay so I woke up and I ordered
a bagel okay and as I was finishing the
bagel I knew like I needed more so I
ordered Serafina and after the Serafina
came I fell asleep for two hours woke up
and order McDonald's it was a really
good day that's really good hi it's such
trouble ordering a bagel yesterday like
I was ordering a smoked salmon like
nothing crazy and I had to choose 13
like the most meats was Birkin where was
like I couldn't place order without
choosing 13 sides like it was that was
the minimum was 13 so glad I'm ordering
from like a horrible Blago place called
suckers you've probably seen it on no I
order from jumbo the bike ride but um he
said not available I don't know I would
read yesterday from Joe
I must submit a mere timer maybe I was
they weren't delivering to my location
yes right whatever
there so I just I wasn't having a
success you know and then I ordered I
sued for dinner and was a lot better I
was inspired by some [ __ ] McFlurry
well signature was snitches McFlurry was
inspired by my McDonald's well I
wouldn't have had what I had without
yours there I go again making everything
about myself how CEO feels good he
really missed me while I was away I was
away for such a long time even though
when I got home I realized it was only a
week and I've probably been away for
longer but this week felt really hard
because Margo is always with me and you
know just like Christ you're never alone
when you're with Margo and I really I
guess I don't feel as homesick when I'm
with mags because she just like reminds
me of home I don't know when like I just
am not alone but everyone knows my
crippling fear is being alone in a hotel
room and just like being alone in
general and I was alone a lot this week
and it was really hard and like for the
I had the longest days ever like I was
up at 6:00 in the morning doing like
morning shows and then working working
on my special secret project and then
driving to my shows and I didn't realize
it when I see it in LA in my shows were
in Irvine and that's like staying in
Manhattan having a show in the Hamptons
Wow yeah so it was really long drives
like late at night all by myself like it
was really just like torturous and I
live I got home and gave mark arrays
like I guess I didn't realize how much
she does like for the actual show but
also also like the morale right and I
really missed her but the shows were
great in Irvine and Brea and I think
that performed really well because like
I had in my mind I'm like there's
totally someone in the audience like who
works for Netflix like cuz they're like
yeah and I just like when I was eight
times she meets never said I was
performing under the influence of like
there being a big time magazine editor
in the audience and I think it really
helps my performance obviously there
wasn't a big time I could scene editor
um but I think that's like a good
mindset to be in for sure and I got to
meet so many prime Joseph's him in a
Lima Hodge era was he everything he was
everything he's like really right he'd
read the comment club like when I got
there like he was the GM that's so funny
that's great yeah it was it just it was
a good week very productive but super
tired I got to go on EJ lollipop which
as we know is like our view and it was
really just a wonderful place like very
welcoming everyone was super nice all of
the camera guys I think they're told to
laugh cuz it definitely like increases
like your vibe when like you say
something funny and then people laugh
okay they don't laugh that so much stuff
though so they're definitely like told
you can laugh if need be this isn't a
silent show but they're they don't just
laugh to laugh well it felt really good
I'm glad your segment was so funny it
was such a good time blue Haley deaf out
of the water
yeah I know I was thinking of telling
her you know how traumatized I was we're
wondering if you were gonna tell her
when I found out that she was the coma I
was that day I found out like the day
before I I thought a lot I had to ponder
because I don't know I just think that
she deserves to know what her sister did
to me when I was in middle school but
you know what her sisters you know
attitude isn't her cross to bear right
and it's like if in 10 years someone
told me you were mean to them at the
Atlantis I'd be like why are you telling
me no I guess that's true and maybe I
was being sensitive to back then but she
really wasn't mean to me my friends so I
didn't say anything but she was cool
yeah I was very conscious and I had my
back towards her cuz I think that's so
rude but I think I ended up doing that
it was fine it was how good it was just
really cool to like be there oh my god I
saw Melanie Bromley and I feel like she
doesn't like us cuz we said that she
only got so far cause of her accent
there's no way she saw us say that the
lady she gave me the dress did and this
show is huge
this show is huge and she gave me leave
crossed the pot and the dirtiest luck
Jackie I was like oh she knows I
suddenly depart coach and I was like I
was walking by her desk and I was like
and she was like you too there was a
good mutual love and respect there
Melanie Bromley not so much I understand
there's no way she knows I would be
shocked well prepare to be sure I just
don't think she's like toast Herrmann
you know I'm constantly I don't saying
she's a toaster but maybe someone
senator I'm constantly like blown away
and have my dishes like send people
stuff just when we've only said
something negative it's so something
positive please right just forget about
the negative yeah I remember we just
stopped saying negative things I'm
trying that's what makes this show
it doesn't make this show this show real
yeah oh she's definitely not a toaster
but she's uh she's seen some of our
content for sure because she like from
across the office she's she's a crumpet
she she's certainly not a chose her
she's a scone did you hear about to meet
us on the garlic bread
what's up came on the toast the Italian
camber was singing me chest on the GAR
you are freaking me up okay are we all
caught up I think so we'll get into it
you know the stories today our story
right there the stories today are bleak
no there they were actually a lot of
stories I'm sorry I forgot one more
thing that I went to a serial Lane mmm
so there's a Universal Studios tour like
anyone can go on it they take you to the
Alamo and all that [ __ ] but just in
like we had an hour
between daily pop and I did his digital
series just the same how did that go it
was the best interview I've ever done he
came in before and he was like I want to
go deep like and talk about everything
and I was like honestly fine I like I
know I've been meaning to like to an
energy to address like the cancellation
of it all and I've been meeting I just
I've just been putting it off but I just
don't like when people like go through
like a cancellation they pretend like it
didn't happen and that's what happens to
Kevin Hart I keep returning didn't
happen then like everyone's like wait it
happened and he didn't want to talk
about anymore so I'm just of the mindset
that I'm gonna start like just
addressing it I guess I don't know
people it's what people want to hear you
know yeah so I did a really good
interview with Justin um and like it was
really emotional
did you drink um it was a glass of rose
a in front of me but I had a diet coke
like behind the scene cuz I asked him
how he gets his guests to open up and I
gave us the keys that's what Andy does
too that's why everyone gets wasted i
watch often he opened you up but it
sounds like you didn't even drink you
just no but with cereal and he took me
on like a golf cart tour which was nice
because we'd have to like we used to
stay in that trailer thing that you do
the Universal Studios tour Ian and I was
like take me to Wisteria Lane so he
showed me all the [ __ ] Alma will and
grace whatever and I'm like take me to
mr. Lane yes so they have the original
set for the Alamo there and it's also
one of like the big attractions on the
Universal Studios tour because they show
you how they flooded the Alamo set in
like two seconds because there's like
these hoses coming out of the window
it's so stupid also like what's the
Alamo so remember it though yeah no I
remember it I just don't remember what
happened
sorry so we went to a cereal Lane and it
was truly one of the most magical
special moments of my life and I didn't
really realize like how affected I was
by that show until I felt the way that I
felt like driving onto Wisteria Lane and
the lane is very much intact a breeze
house was nowhere to be found Justin
said that like they sometimes they
literally pick up houses and move them
and paint them different colors or shoot
inside them just for like houses so
Brees house could have been taken
somewhere else but I saw Bob and Lee's
the Solis house I didn't see Susan's but
I saw Lynette's and that little like
alcove cul-de-sac that they like had
their parties in oh yeah yeah but what's
so interesting it's like in that little
garden whose house was there
Edie's right mmm yeah this is the end of
the road yeah in the cul-de-sac which is
where the little garden okay but like in
on the set it was a totally different
house it was just so interesting and I
really felt like like a special like I
was like dying
and then I went to a Gabi so Lisa's
house [ __ ] dare I say the most iconic
of the houses and the most recognizable
and the door was open I became very nice
the door was open but it smelled she
doesn't smell it smelled really bad
because I guess like it's uninhabited
homes like for years and it was really
cool cuz they definitely filmed inside
the house because the layout was told us
he and the stairs were on the right the
kitchen dining was on the left but it
was truly it was really amazing like I
felt like I could die like I could have
stayed there all day and it was really
just as beautiful like besides the smell
like it was green lush breakfast it was
anyone there talking about bringing back
no but there was a crew in one of the
garages I guess filming like just
pretending to be another house I saw
Mike delfino's house they painted it it
was really cool it was like honestly
like it was I think better than being on
daily pop which was like our dream it
was really like iconic no it looked it
what else was is a rosewood there from
Pretty Little Liars well no but I was
driving we were driving through these
random town so I'm like this looks so
familiar and but they were using it
right then and there for a town called
like Sequoia or something no no that's
not right but I'm like why does this
Town Square look so familiar
and I'm like it looks like Heart of
Dixie and then someone told me that they
found Heart of Dixie on that lot so it
was totally hard of Dixie Oh like
Bluebell like you know where the the
shops are which would have died are you
caught up on dynasty
no but I know I need to be because I'm
freaking out it's so crazy I have little
motivation I have to catch up on shows
that are not reality no I agree except
for dynasty like I literally a paint I
don't have CW on YouTube TV I can't
watch alive I can only watch on Saturday
morning dynasty and I like countdown
like I'm so obsessed with it it's so
good I'm so shocked by what's going on
and I just need to know I know I haven't
seen stop stop stop stop okay I believe
we are all caught up now and if you want
we can jump into the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
okay first story is really sad Grammy
nominated rap
Nipsey Hussle killed in LA shooting
grammy-nominated rapper Nipsey Hussle
reportedly was killed in a shooting
outside his la clothing store on Sunday
sources told NBC News that two other
people were shot as well but survived
Hustle 33 had sent out an ominous tweet
just hours earlier saying quote having
strong enemies is a blessing quote how
ironic is this man will wrote one
Twitter user in response hustle and LA
native was nominated for Best Rap Album
at this year's Grammy Awards for his
debut studio album victory lap his
clothing store is located in 3400 block
of slough sin Avenue in Hyde Park police
officials said the shooting happened
around 3:20 p.m. local time the gunman
was still at large Sunday night LAPD
tweeted we have no suspect info at this
time and we'll provide more details as
they become available that's so sad I
didn't realize how many people knew him
like Kim did an Instagram story
everyone's really talking about him I
was unfamiliar with this work but this
is so sad because he left behind a wife
and two kids so sad really like so sad
so senseless what are people gonna stop
shooting each other that's just my
question you know yeah like this is very
Tupac
oh wait biggie by Tupac I don't know but
like it's like that was 50 years ago and
like it's still happening look let's
evolve you guys yeah it's it's really
sad shot there's no way you could
survive like it but then sometimes it's
like you'll watch a show or hear a story
and it's like what the person survived
wait like two other peoples are about
right I guess it's just where you got
shot right and like how far away ya know
it's just a senseless violence that's
constantly being perpetuated in our
televisions and video games and you know
what it's not good you know it ain't
good I'm some California oh my god I
went to to get some socks it's just this
random store it's like an athletic it's
like a Foot Locker they were selling
guns why it was the weirdest thing and
the line was so long for checkout that
they were like the gun checkout can take
you if you're paying credit card and I
like went to the gun checkout and I was
just like freaking out wait she's like I
motels that's so crazy I know is it
legal to own guns like that in
California I guess it was honestly like
the scariest thing ever and I was like I
just I just didn't like it like being
this confined space with all these
strangers I got all these guns that is
so great it was really like shocking I
don't know what though I don't not
caught
my laws but I know in New York they're
kind of strict but like when I was in
Chicago I went to him like a Bulls game
and I guess you can carry a gun in
Chicago and on all the doors at the
Bulls game it was like jumping your
weapons in it's like the fact that you
have to say that like that's my worst
nightmare being in there an arena you
know how much of the next game tonight
Oh Ben's birthday I like I really just I
don't know who I think I am but um the
amount of money I've spent on Ben's
birthday this far is out of control
oh I thought you were just like cuttin
corners often right no I mean I still
kind of corners the party I got a great
discount cause girls trust her but like
still so much money the club afterwards
no discount there and I was just being
like drunk like yeah it's pretty model
she comes back she's like your card was
declined
oh my god I put on bed scarred like
literally oh you didn't know I get I
been match like I wanted to be like my
money just paying for it cause like it's
his birthday he shouldn't have to shell
out a dollar and then I got him floor
seats to the Knicks tonight which like I
just feel like they should be able to
get like someone to give me tickets like
I hate asking for favors you know so I
feel were they really expensive no but
you know little [ __ ] StubHub and
their fees they're out of control
because the ticket prices worn that
crazy but once I got put them in my cart
the two with handling fees to step up
these it was a lot more than I expected
oh wait that was [ __ ] I'm sorry to
hear that and then what'd you get him as
a gift or the ticket to the gift I want
to say because maybe he watch is
watching there's no way he's like I'm
trying to get him anything yet yeah it
was just I figure it out yeah he's an
easy man
also keep Wednesday night open for
dinner he'd like forgot to text everyone
but I didn't need to tell you okay I
think I might have made up I need a
coffee plan that's okay tomorrow night I
have my cooking class where JCCC well
I'm not gonna tell you guys where I'm
gonna be but oh god yeah there was a
show uh one of the various JCC's and so
what are you gonna go it's a culinary
boot camp and Kiro in there it's a
culinary boot camp every Tuesday for the
next three weeks in three weeks time I'm
gonna know how to cook wait is it too
late to sign up I don't think so when is
it Tuesday every the next three Tuesdays
at 6:30 at the JCC maybe I'll come I
think that you should I'll know how to
cook in three weeks time okay we okay do
you to eat it afterwards is it at the
JCC as a kosher and I didn't sign up for
a coach or specific but like it's the
food you're making gonna be like I'm
probably not at the JCC
I didn't inquire wait when I got into my
uber today was meat demand
I've been now very conscious of my uber
like um I don't the word it's a
characteristics because of this horrible
story that happened to the girl in the
University of South Carolina who got
into a car that wasn't her goober and
was dead the next day and now I've been
like getting and being like what's the
name usually my kisses for Claudia no
you tell me who this is for yeah I
always checked the license plate me too
and you can never be too sick you can
never be too safe and I always check I
always look for the phone in the car
that says Jackie but I guess I shouldn't
I should just open the window and be
like who are you for before I get I get
in and it's too late they're like my
sister Claudia like no you know like
yeah but so I got in and there was the
BBC Radio playing and usually put in my
ear pods but the second I couldn't they
were talking with a Holocaust I'm like
oh what now in Belarus ready for this
they're building flats as Americans say
apartments and when they broke ground
they found another mass grave look
imagine think because so many people
were killed that literally like 100
years later like you're still finding
bodies and the first two days they found
a thousand bodies with bullet holes in
the skull oh my god how terrible is that
that's horrible and there are people who
deny the Holocaust like legit come to my
house and say that's my face I'll
[ __ ] knock you out I got a new lip
gloss from you saying Nick's or NYX I
say and my ex I say next but I think
that's your wearing Nick's at the next
game oh my god totally okay so say a lip
oil how's it look it looks nice okay
are you ready for the next story yeah
cuz Chrissy Teigen is being unbelievably
relatable and saying that she's
accepting being 20 pounds heavier oh my
god I read this and totally loved her
Chrissy Teigen is perfectly fine with
being 20 pounds heavier the 33 year old
supermodel and cookbook author took to
Twitter over the weekend to discuss her
weight burp talking with fans Teigen
revealed that she hasn't lost the way
she gettin her last pregnancy how do you
meet like this the star tweeted
basically I'm 20 pounds heavier than I
was before miles he's 10 months old I
never lost that last bit because I just
love food too much just coming to terms
with my new normal when I had this
certain number for so long Teagan and
husband John Legend are often on social
media showing their chef's skills by
preparing delicious meals for themselves
and their friends she also explained
when life was like after giving birth to
the couple's first child Luna quote the
thinnest I've ever been was right after
Luna
postpartum depression I'll take these
pounds and this feeling right it's so
interesting it's so interesting because
she comes from a model background where
you have to look a certain way but at
the same time she's really like
a very inspiring way turned herself into
like this home brand and she's oh he's
cooking and stuff so honestly wouldn't
really make sense if she's still like
was like that model tiny skinny while
also like making fried chicken for John
right you know so I appreciate her
authenticity and curating a brand right
so I hadn't noticed that she's 20 pounds
heavier so good for her she's just
beautiful that's true actually but also
like she's tall and like she's she looks
great 20 pounds on her is like 5 pounds
on me and you do notice it totally um I
actually was thinking last night about
it's funny how I only get motivated to
like work out like once only at night
and then I wake up and I was like what
was I thinking
you know it's like when you make a
drunken mistake like last I was like I
should work out this week but then I
woke up and I was like maybe not musical
Monday maybe I just opened my open fit
and I'm all good from there you know
yeah so that's nice to start getting fit
and staying healthy Oh buddy sounds
easier to said than done right true
especially if you say to yourself at
night open fit is bringing you something
new that makes it even easier to never
miss a sweat session lose the commute to
the gym and let the workouts come to you
open if it takes all the complexity out
of losing weight and getting fit it's a
brand new super simple streaming service
that allows you to work out from the
comfort of your literally and if
screaming so maybe we should stream
there and then also host like in
aerobics classes it's our own musical
Monday today totally it's super simple
forget all the complexity and stress
around getting fit and just press play
workout on your schedule 600 seconds
with celebrity trainer Devin Wiggins
packs of fat burning muscle building and
body sculpting benefits of much longer
sessions into a fraction of the time
right now during the open fit 30-day
challenge our listeners got a special
extended 30-day free trial membership to
open fit where you can lose up to 15
pounds in 30 days when you text toast to
30 30 30 that's 3 0 3 0 3 0 text toast
to 30 30 30 you'll get full access to
open fit all the workouts and
nutritional information totally free
again text toast to just 30 30 30 nice I
love a good streaming I've I love
Chrissy Teigen just being like relatable
I feel like we I used to like things she
was like annoyingly relatable and just
like would say and do stuff for the sake
of being related mode it was just
BuzzFeed hitting her against us right
yeah now I feel like she is relatable
you know this is really relatable what
you say relatable it seems really happy
in her life you know she has a full life
but it's like always like the proof is
in the pudding like she could talk about
being happy
mr. gladden it's like this is annoying
but it's how she's living her life that
says the most yeah she's got a nice
family career he's in order and remember
the time which I don't know where she's
at now but when she wasn't drinking cuz
she was like I was just getting drunk
and like being in back and embarrassing
John yeah
relatable truly unbelievably I won't do
ever did you wake up with a pin on
Sunday no I didn't you know I believe
was so measured in my drinking plus I
started drinking much earlier in the day
so my pit would have hit me like later
in the day honestly I think I really
just timed it all out really nicely I'm
happy for you yeah it's taken years to
figure this out perfect it's time last
year I remember I was trying to figure
it out a Penn's birthday at his 90s
party and I was like I'm gonna be
measured I can't be hungover because
we're starting the toast on Monday and
it didn't work so well we are coming up
on the one-year anniversary of the toast
and honestly I just like don't know how
to feel I don't know like how to
properly celebrate so April 9th is the
one year so we'll be here obviously
doing a show unlike being toasty and
we'll probably just take a trip down
memory lane okay like back to the first
show no oh my god that's scary so scary
such a big face reach or should I say
back literally or just like I should I
say welcome to the morning toes back to
the first show what do you do with your
iPad okay you were on a really big cool
lot like Jam back then I think the key
word there is big because me right now
okay that's fair yeah and they were
really comfortable but it's like but
you're starting a morning show who cares
about comfort right no no you've where
were mangy you've sold yourself she
would the Hoda leeandcathy gods and this
is the price you have to pay right and
you know what I'm really enjoying it I
feel like I've really been stepping up
my wardrobe for the show because like
dress for the show you want not the
streaming show that you have agreed um
and it's really just it's been very
positive yeah it's been very positive
that first day of the toast is humbling
but you know what and I love the pants
then there's the show can only get
better yeah there's nowhere else to go
well I loved our Access Hollywood piece
except for the fact that they included
clips from the first show
like we've come so far please let some
of the first show and like if we weren't
fat they weren't interested in the photo
right right which was hilarious and
there was a nice change well first of
all I was just humbling brand it was a
nice nice - you can't forget where you
came from right and it was also like
only six months ago and it was a nice
change of pace no jelly I was a year ago
no but like they were using photos from
Nashville which for me Oh photos well
yeah personally an attack my biggest
yeah looks like how does the editor and
access know like I'm not gonna like this
photo but why were they going back to
June I don't know it just seems like
extra work for that
yeah jelly Papa put a bag you fiddly
VARs figured it out [ __ ] go [ __ ] Bo
exactly right anyways we'll talk about
all of our thoughts on all of this next
week and we're just gearing up for the
one year you know the toast is finally
getting its baby teeth truly we're gonna
start biting huh
okay next up Chris Rock rips Jessie
Smollett and double-a-c-p Image Awards
so you haven't been here since the
Jessie smell it drama has continued to
unfold the charges were dropped
some people just assumed he was innocent
me naive [ __ ] no they were just dropped
yeah there's some shitty famous there's
some shady business going on here and I
loved well so when I was on Access
Hollywood this week there was lot of
speculation about whether Jesse would
show up because he was nominated for an
image we're supporting actor um and he
was in LA so they thought he was really
gonna show up and I'm glad that he
didn't because honestly like so much of
my my mind my time my life has been
occupied by this story all for nothing
because justice has never been gonna be
served but what I thought was really
interesting first of all what Chris Rock
said about it just easy this is it he
said he was hosting the awards he said
they said no Jesse small at jokes I know
what a waste of white skin you know what
I could do with that light skin it says
white skin here oh I thought it was love
you and then he said you know what I
could do with that light skin that curly
hair my career would be out of here
[ __ ] running Hollywood what the hell
was he thinking from now on you're Jesse
from now on you don't even get the you
know more that you was respect you don't
get no respect for me so true but then
Yara Shahidi
came on and she said I stand with Jesse
and honestly I just started walking
watching blackish and I loved it and
this was really disappointing cuz like
no
yes some people on the red carpet said
that they they believed him to like I
mean I guess it's like you know waste
I guess now like you have to believe him
right I don't know I truly don't know
what to think okay so I believe him sure
but what about okay so those attackers
let's get him right right all right yeah
so the charges aren't gonna be filed on
him then someone's guilty right it's
like a Casey Anthony did he murder her
daughter
then who did let's get him right great
call justice heard Nicole Brown Simpson
talk about her right in the eyes of the
law it's not true so we're whether I
believe him or I don't either way
there's no justice being served well
it's just there's just Jesse there's
Jesse I can't even with this story jesse
has been sir have you seen the clip
going around of this guy he won an award
and gave Beyonce a kiss yes it was
really awkward he was and he's getting a
lot of [ __ ] and like Beyonce looks
really visibly uncomfortable I'm like it
was weird it was weird it was full of
weirdness that was weird it was
weirdness and like a lot of touching and
like if it was if he gave his sometimes
you do accidentally come close to the
mouth we've all been there but he gave
it to perfectly fine she's right it
could have known another kiss on that
night size on that he went side cheek
hug and then when I get and then corner
of lip legit I would his same size
quarter Beyonce she looked so
uncomfortable she looks so uncomfortable
and I was like she didn't want to be
looking uncomfortable because like she
was just like that like being a woman
you just want to like be a trooper and
not make someone feel bad but and I'm
not like have every incident be like I
feel whatever in that moment I just like
so she was five different stages comfort
that was horrible ya know back to Jessie
I'm so glad he didn't show up I'm like
really done with him and like I really
hope because he doesn't deserve to ever
work in this town again but I feel like
I feel like he'll be fine
do you know I don't know why I feel that
way I don't know I think he'll be fine
as a person I don't think he's gonna
work again I don't think anyway like and
at first I thought they would totally
have him back on Empire because they
can't fire him because he'd enjoy the
thing wrong tonight so they would keep
him because also this is such a big
story now like you know all press is
good press
but apparently Empire
had its worst ratings ever last week
which is a sign of people protesting the
show I think they're gonna have to
cancel the show there's no way out of
this no yes because they can't bring him
back if justice Millette brought down
when our biggest jokes apparently was
already on the decline okay
and without it's the rating so I think
people are just like they're done with
this show and like I think it's
tarnished that's so crazy
hmm it'll be interesting I mean it's
definitely tarnish and like all them
really came out for Jessie when the
incident first happened like really
showing like sign of support we're a
family and then like nothing was ever
heard from the Empire cast like ever
again yeah I watch it in everywhere
someone asked cookie about it and she
was just like really brushed it off like
and didn't really address it head-on
yeah because there's nothing you can say
oh so I'm sure they're friends with him
so like right you're not gonna publicly
bash also like why is it on them to
speak on this idiots behalf it's not
there I mean it's become their cross to
bear but it shouldn't be yeah I think I
understand why people would be asking
his co-workers like oh I'm just curious
what their thoughts are but I don't feel
like it's on them to either like condemn
or agree or whatever no but like no
matter what they say it's gonna affect
the show so it's just like there and
lose-lose totally and it's all pretty
[ __ ] messy if you ask me I mean the
messiness of it all just is not lost so
I mean like honestly the must eNOS is
Jessie's cross to bear yeah and I'll
leave it at that
speaking of muss and fuss Northwest's
had the best day ever while hanging out
with Joe Josie why did you watch the
video of course okay you've never seen
glitter or rainbows until you've seen
the inside of Joe Josie US House and
Northwest can surely attest to this Kim
Kardashian and Kanye West's oldest child
spent the day with the YouTube star
chose home where they made literally
slime played hide and seek had a dance
party north can do the splits and looked
at cars she acted as North's caretaker
for the day and the two of them filmed
their highly anticipated YouTube video
together the title is babysitting
Northwest okay well first of all there
were so many things about the video that
just really shook me the first is [ __ ]
Jojo C was house I actually have watched
her home tour before and she's like a
little weird about her house like there
are certain rooms that you can't go
unless she's pretty nene leakes man yes
because I want to talk about
closet gate okay when
a films her home toward the show this
showed like random rims it's like
obviously her parents like decorated the
other parts of the house that like that
I don't allowed yeah but like when she
was like North wait here and she like
went to go get something oh no what she
was looking for North in one of the
rooms for hide-and-seek she told the
camera she's like stay here and she went
in the room like she's weird about rooms
in her house I noticed that here I know
it was very easy leaks and then the
second thing I noticed is the North West
is extremely shy she was so shy she was
so cute
oh my god I she's so cute I can't also
Kim saying that st. was her favorite
with so it's what you're taught like
that's that's its nature over her to
recap Kardashian I need to talk about
Jojo and North first of all I thought
don't you see wow it was like the
youngest kid out here doing it no she's
enormous like she's like [ __ ] me
compared to North she's 40 years old and
it's like George I was looking to get
like respect and like you know be taken
seriously as a mature adult this was the
way to do it because like I thought she
was North West you know what she's
actually really young but she's like a
giant she's so tall she's nine nine
sorry what five she's by nine that's
what people were saying hold on I have
to do that for me it was really my first
glad I just started following Jojo see
you on Instagram and like watching this
video was the first time I seen her
you're right
five nine and then her age it was my
first oh oh my god she's [ __ ] six
feet but like how old is north six I
thought they were the same until I
watched this videos honestly they are
like eight year olds I thought hmm but
compared to North Kona just seems like
wise beyond her years
no wait I'm literally shook by the 5/9
of it all and he's like someone I
thought someone should be babysitting
Josie oh yeah I was a babysitter
no Joe Josie well like has a car that
she can't drive right except like 50
year olds can drive everyone can drive
except for me
Yeah right anyway my god wait that's so
crazy I can't get over the 5/9 of it all
the video was cute it was our first
foray into Lake North West's person
company and it was also a very big step
towards Northwest becoming the enormous
youtuber she's gonna be and like she
really was so shy
overwhelmed and cute and her [ __ ]
outfit like I could die and you know
like oh and honey it doesn't ever let
her just like make a car like like
sparkly skirts like in their backpack
konpai saw that he would vomit no it's
so true it's like the opposite of ZZ
season and like when she saw the bows
and she doubled up she's like do you
want one or two she was a double she was
she's really [ __ ] precious honestly
she was a precious to chat with a woman
totally oh my god that's so true about
the outfit and like her big-ass ponytail
it's a she's always wearing like kids
supply yeah I'm gonna totally ripped
sweaters with like biker shorts yeah but
now she's not to wear like real kids
clothes from Target yes I think like
that was like that was the gift for her
right she lives in a house with no
furniture it's like the sunken place
right which George's house is like her
dream honestly the way Northwest felt at
George's he wasn't house was probably
like how I felt it was Tyrion like
meeting your heroes and I don't it was
clear that North had never made sign
before like she obviously didn't know
what she was doing we've had more
experience with Karina Garcia yeah
honestly making slime is [ __ ] missing
and honestly I really could see how
spoiled North West is she was making
such a big [ __ ] man yeah and didn't
even look down at the floor to see all
the sparkles you know Hearts bottles are
clear up Joe's gonna see his mom it's
just going to force no but like Jones is
coming out with like a smartphone
cleaner that she's selling on QVC so you
know do you want one of Joe Joe's juice
she was really Hawking all the products
I got and I'm sure North has never had
juice like that right oh she only eats
like organic salads from that place that
she shakes but honestly like Joe Joe is
a thirst monster general I have nothing
but respect for her in the ocean and
what she's done and like I was reading
some tweets where it was like jojo's
offering north tickets to her concert
with her friend says if North could just
buy everything I'll see Italy
North has a box and isn't it like at the
LA place where her aunt Shelly owns the
forum Shelly owns a four I'm pretty sure
[ __ ] oh yeah something something like
that so it's like North was like [ __ ]
I'm going to please I'm fine
anyways it was really cute I loved the
clap I love that it came out on the day
of Kardashian's premiere which actually
felt to me like this was actual
marketing trying to reach a younger
demographic not as young as we thought
no but if you think about it like young
just showing up and doing the video with
north like jojo's channel is whatever is
gonna blow up like so Kim she gets
something out of it - and Kim did it
because like first of all she Kim is
always saying relatable she did it
because it's North his North's dream but
she wanted to get something out of it
too so she was promoting the [ __ ] of it
just like [ __ ] Jo Jo with shelling
out her bows yeah I want to know how
many views it's up to now cuz when I
watched and I probably watch like an
hour after it came out it was only at 26
K which is like kind of embarrassing
well no when a video goes up and out of
use it doesn't automatically we had it
but no it's been a day oh it's a million
point one pretty good one of her other
videos also they were filming it for
Kardashians I saw the other cameras in
the background her other videos get oh
god sorry I don't want to get like
copyright Jo Jo see what TV oh my god
she's three and a half million
subscribers she got her ears pierced
again sponsored by three and a half
million subscribers not that that's not
a lot but like she's always hanging out
with like the youtubers who have like 15
mil I don't know but she has she gets
between like hundred thousand and two
and a half million video views on a
video so one day having a million is a
lot yeah
wait I'm shocked that's like not that
much just for like the youtubers status
that she is I guess she's gotten so
famous mainstream just cuz of the way
she looks and like acts yeah but like
James Charles is finally now like known
as like a celebrity just because you
can't ignore him he's 15 million
subscribers holy [ __ ] yeah and he just
[ __ ] kills it I love watching his
videos I'm totally a sister interesting
well anyways I just loved this look how
[ __ ] oh yes Julia Julia be Beyonce
she is I'm at Julie big eonni made a
really good point like her cameraman was
so shaky I was so nauseous
I felt so old how was that I guess
that's her style like you know like the
office yeah she is the cameraman like
kind of tremor you know but that's her
style is like Nickelodeon like whoa do
it again do it again is it oh my god
totally it was really making me so
[ __ ] nauseous if you guys haven't seen
the Z shirt sketch on us and now it's so
fun five years ago you're missing out
you haven't lived Oh Myung they just got
okay did them vinyl story a little
business that's affecting all your
favorites
snacky o's
oh my god I'm so hungry Kellogg sells
Keebler and Famous Amos to get out of
cookies Kellogg is getting out of the
cookie business to focus on snacks and
cereal wait but the cookie is a snack
it's a cookie
this is incredibly interesting Ferrero
will by Kellogg's ki Boucher brochet
Kellogg's Keebler Famous Amos mother's
Marie's Girl Scout cookies and fruit
snacks brands for one point three
billion dollars that's shocking that
there would offload Girl Scouts because
like they're really a popular brand and
they're like good for like business and
just yeah Ferrero makes Nutella tic tacs
and for our Rocher chocolates among
other confectionery tax yeah so weird
like the conglomerates you know like
[ __ ] Pepsi owns Taco Bell you know
yeah it is weird it's full of
interesting factoids
Sooey what is your favorite Kellogg
snack that is no longer being like this
is I'm really bored of those Keebler
stripes yes
so [ __ ] good and I love Famous Amos
when I see that yellow bag you know it's
in for a good time and it's like it's
not an assaulting yellow it's like a
nice it's me yeah it's like a mob well
no not even it's a chartreuse it's like
a buttery yellow
it's a butterscotch we jegi I feel like
it'd rather say something no I'm gonna
say something interesting but I forgot
give me cheese two seconds you asked me
what my favorite snack was um oh when
you say Keebler can you think of
anything other than dancing around like
the Keebler Elf okay I've got around the
same age too
did you know that the guy who made
Famous Amos was on Shark Tank the season
did you watch you know you know Shark
Tank hasn't been doing I know and it's
because so I watch a on Sunday nights in
the bedroom Zac watches on the couch you
watch a shark tanking well you guys are
sleeping in separate beds
already we just really like he doesn't
like the bed and I don't like to be on
the couch I had the same thing would
become something I don't see him you
know and it's so nice because like we
never really feels like we don't see
each other enough which is a great place
to be and as opposed to like totally
over saturation happens either right so
I've been loving a Sunday night
programming will talk about Kardashians
and I went and then then the other night
he invited me to watch Turkey with him
on the couch I was like okay hubs that
sounds nice
and they went I was like this is like so
not interesting and not what it used to
be and it was just wasn't doing it for
me anymore so I I haven't been watching
this news it's gotten like a little
stale like I never thought cuz they have
the perfect for him it I never thought
like into
it's like SVU it's a type of show that
doesn't need to change but I'm kind of
like over it it's gotten stale I saw
like undies for men last night that had
like butt pads in them and they were
taking them so seriously mr. wonderful
made a deal and I just have a problem
with a lot of like the rules on the show
the fact like if someone offers you
something like you can't entertain
anyone elses offer it's like these are
these people's businesses it's their
lives no and they only make that real
for certain people right like sometimes
if they're feeling threatened like
they'll be like right now you gotta say
it Barbara loves to do that nobody
nobody listens right yeah anyways back
to business Kellogg has been trying to
sell off those brands since November it
is said the brand's weren't a good fit
with the rest of the company's offerings
and the company had difficulty devoting
resources necessary to compete in the
crowded cookie market last year the
business's Kellogg is selling to Ferrero
brought in about 900 million dollars in
sales but only 75 million dollars in
operating profit quote divesting these
great brands wasn't an easy decision
said Steve Cal hain Kellogg CEO in a
statement now that sounds like a nice
job I just can't imagine like Kellogg's
not being like a successful brand like I
mean I go grocery shopping here in New
York I went grocery shopping when we
were in Utah and they had Keebler all
over the place like there really are in
every home in America how is it not
successful no wait is successful but I
think they're saying they weren't able
to dedicate a lot of resources to it so
like this year they made nine hundred
million dollars without any probably any
good new commercials this or that that's
true they you should have the little
elves in the oven and the cookies and
the little lodge right they've got into
mr. Dean's dancing around like the
Keebler Elf exactly and now that's been
put on the back burner it still makes
money but they're gonna give it to a
company well they're gonna sell it at a
profit to a company that's gonna make it
a priority it's gonna be happy to have
them because it seems like Kellogg's
trying to move to like snacks and cereal
like I wouldn't be surprised there try
these catalogs all the General Mills
know the conglomerates just out several
males is like a separate conglomerate
competitor of Kellogg's yeah got it it's
like the Kellogg's of General Mills got
it yeah well what else is Kellogg's own
Froot Loops Rice Krispies Willie mm-hmm
Pringles Pringle pop charts cheez-its
Club crackers the Blues profitable
no Club crackers are two profitable than
car advertising yeah but they're good
crackers actually delicious yeah they're
gonna like when you're at a club like an
elevated Ritz
yeah even the Ritz are fine just our
formula why do we have to change him no
we don't well what an interesting
business news segment yeah just
something you should know when you're
like picking up a local Keebler cookie
at your local supermarket also we don't
have a six-story but if we did it would
be the fact that Elon Musk released a
song today
yeah called r.i.p Harambee and it's a
[ __ ] bob and it's hilarious
and they just think it's so sweet and I
know everyone's saying he's on drugs and
maybe this is an April Fool's prank
right but um you know what if this is
him on drugs like this is the worst of
him other people like go on drugs and
then they like you know punch someone in
the face or like get a DUI and he gets
like hi and writes a song about Harambee
right no he honestly happened this is
the Texas really need this is a real
like inside look into the soul of Elon
Musk and I feel like he's a good person
yeah it's like a DS craziest didn't
worse he just wants to sing about
Harambee you know and his words like he
just doesn't want the memory of like a
good gorilla to be forgotten right and
like that's something I can respect I
was having this conversation with Ben
yesterday I'm like I really don't
understand like how humans came from
apes can you explain that and like also
like how humans came from apes but like
also there are still Apes around like
why didn't they turn into humans that's
true it's like the whole evolution of
like that that diagram it's like a an
ape and then he turns into a man Hilary
definitely yeah I don't [ __ ]
understand
yeah is that real or is that like a
science myth okay Society has accepted
that it is real and now some people who
are religious are like well know Adam
and Eve were just plopped down on earth
like humans but science and religion
have come together to figure out a way
to make both makes sense and that's the
school that I subscribe to which is
because I which is that like Adam in
need for a beeps what no I don't know
but there is a way to because I believe
in Adam and Eve but there's a way that
you can believe in Adam and Eve and
evolution
I forget how exempt a turn into a map
the world has accepted that evolution is
is that evolution the ape thing yes well
I believe in evolution - right and so
you are an ape see I just I don't I
don't get that you know yeah I don't I'm
not gonna speak on it because I don't
understand really either I just have
accepted it because like I want to watch
that movie where they argue about it for
a long time in court yes speaking of
crazy thing College I don't know I need
to find it the movie about evolution or
it's in a book speaking of the crazy
things people
I'm going to Clearwater Florida on this
weekend actually I'm doing two shows
head to girl with no job come for
tickets in Orlando and Clearwater which
is almost sold out and Clearwater is
apparently the HQ for Scientology
I heard finally someone messaged me
they're like be careful
they send their spies to like local
people who perform to make sure you're
not like joking and that you're not a
suppressed person oh my god and honestly
I'm scared when I read it but now I
literally I didn't even know that I was
shut girl didn't tell me because now I
literally can't stop talking about
Scientology and you know what I'm gonna
[ __ ] talk about it you find out what
you're looking for I don't know what I
can't remember if it's a book Arabic
split us okay so it's like I guess it
was a court trial where they put it on
trial creationism versus evolution well
you you watch the board [ __ ] I know it
isn't something I had to watch in school
and why is the Big Bang Theory called
the Big Bang it's a big flash play
someone said it's totally a play Joey
why is the Big Bang Theory on CBS called
that um like I know what the Big Bang
Theory is like someone things like the
world is banged and the world came it
was big and banged what they call that
stupid show that because they're
scientists oh and I don't want to find
out you know the less I know about that
show I think the more pure my mind will
say yeah I guess it was Edwards versus
AG Willard but that doesn't mean I don't
know that I'm freaked I don't know but I
don't know what are you this is like the
farm on Riverdale you're not caught up
on Riverdale I'm officially done
watching Riverdale and you know I feel
like my life is really just later I'm
enjoying it like it's not like dynasty
where I'm like if I don't watch it I
can't ever talk to snitch again but
right I'm enjoying it
what are you deaf to the show everything
no just kidding I'm gonna start to be
good because we're going to Coachella
and like I just don't want to be I don't
want to be the biggest person there okay
Jackie and I are going to Coachella
Coachella obviously that's what it is
because I get so much [ __ ] chub-rub
at my couch no we're gonna Coachella and
we're gonna be partnering with purvey
rivo sunglasses and I just ordered 75
pairs and she's like send over your bags
I'm like okay I sent over the whole
website I think I'm really excited
actually I feel like we went once we
learned what not to do now we're going
back with the right type of parking pass
the right type of outfits the right
scheduling like you go once you get to
learn there's a learning curve with
Coachella yeah now we're going back with
I think a fresh set of
yeah and a fresh set of sunglasses
courtesy of purveyor of oh um awesome
just pissed for not going the second
weekend because that's why I know I'm
he's doing his church I'm really upset
because I like I'm Jewish but I would
totally be in there oh man
I was watching Kim's videos yesterday of
the church and I forgot what they were
saying but it was so good I was smiling
like everyone in the choir looks so
happy and when they were when they were
on the plane and they found out they
were doing Coachella like oh wait I'm
late when Zach was here when we were
just talking these people on the plane
the band member yes oh where were they
going I don't know I was like what is
this plane when Zach was here we were
talking about um whenever we watch it
Kanye's Church and he was saying like I
feel like this is a tour rehearsals and
they're gonna take it on tour like this
is gonna be his next tour and I was like
that would be so cool but I didn't
believe I put with Coachella like they
over there trying to act and yet on the
road though the Blue Man Group I'm so
here for it I think that know what the
world could use like a little more
gospel a little more I listened to a lot
of music I was listening to a song that
I've been listening to for a while and
it's you say yeah I'm lost and Eagle
today I was listening it's a courtesy
song yes I don't know why I'm like
really drawn to Christian music it's a
Jewish person so trying to Christian I
love that song I love that song I love
her Lauren eagle that one song really
has crossed over into the mainstream so
you didn't even like it was really like
subliminal like Franchesca about a Tele
we love her it's all so good it's so
good even Lauren Alaina she lives you go
to a Christian music festival okay like
I just think that maybe they tame him a
little too far just like that's shoes I
use but the music is good you know what
they're singing about god I'm here we
think about it differently but you know
what we're still singing about God right
and it's the same book yeah and Jesus
was a Jew so we're all good yeah okay
well I think that's all her - Ian oh yes
okay so many things that I want to talk
about in Kardashian's series premiere no
season premiere one Kanye doing
interviews yes so exciting however they
used it was like a Trojan horse they use
Kanye doing interviews to service an
episode about Kourtney's anxiety over a
bridge yeah it was so stupid but I like
how they kept talking like very meta
breaking down the fourth wall being like
he's like I never wanted to do these
what are they called yes they have such
an interesting dynamic Kim is really
different around Kanye than she is
everyone else she talks differently to
which
that car she was like that's whack like
no Kim stop like I would she was also
being like just like you don't want to
say anything to like wake the Beast of
copying but she also was able to like
she could talk straight to him and she
was right like he doesn't really have
anyone else know is happy but they
definitely have an interesting dynamic
where like she's in charge and like he's
dead stuff and like looks at her to make
sure it's okay yeah which is what a
marriage should be which isn't yeah she
is in charge because which is perfect
cuz it allows him when she said he was a
free thinker he was like so turned on it
was like the best thing anyone could
ever say about him no totally
I think they're so cute they they
definitely had a rough time in Chicago
and I feel like this episode is gonna be
about like rockiness between them I
think that ultimately they're gonna be
fine but it must be hard why they all so
just so interesting the evolution of
Kanye in relation to the show because
when they first met he was never on it
didn't want North on it and like slowly
but surely like it's becoming all about
them right and the show is really like
he really looked down on the show yes
now the show is really the vessel
through which they get out their true
stories it's like even when something
happens I there's Taylor Swift or Jordan
woods like they'll wait the six months
until it comes out on the show and then
they are justified they think he really
expect I think he thought it was like
trashy when they first met and like
wanted nothing to do with it but I think
literally like Yeezy has like made
millions of dollars from nacho ya know
and it's like the only way to get your
truth out there and I think it's also
why he's always on Kim's Instagram story
he's like he like it's better that she's
posting about this and getting the word
out about what he's doing rather than
like the media picking up on one piece
of it totally so it's good anyways I'm
obsessed with that Palm Springs house
that Kris Jenner bought oh my god the
most I've ever so watch what happens I'd
when Kourtney was about to spilt like
then she was saying well Kris just
bought a vacation house and Chloe kind
of like shut her up and it turns out I
was in Palm Springs I thought it's gonna
be like Borg or something what's so
interesting is that they're all so rich
and none of them have secondary homes
they all had one huge house in Calabasas
Kanye has an apartment in New York and
that's it
well and they think that's so weird and
it's so much nicer to go away somewhere
and have everything taken care of and
you don't worry about like plumbing and
stuff but because Palm Springs is so
close you don't be able to use it so
often and that makes me think that
they're all gonna go to Coachella I'm
like maybe stagecoach you know but it's
not good at every festival it's just
like a rich person thing to do because
you like invest in properties and you
have people to maintain it for you and I
always thought it was just so
interesting how like none of them have
secondary homes and the fact that Kris
Jenner is one about the house it is the
nicest house it's literally huge and
they haven't they didn't show the
outside
of course usually they pretend yeah or
like they'll show in the back yeah no
they didn't they just they and they
showed the back because we got the pool
which was really fun they were drinking
a lot and you know what they needed they
needed brew mate because honestly those
drinks looked warm drinks looked for
brew me combines fashion with function
no more boring drink we're unlike other
brands that only cater to the
outdoorsman or outdoor fanatic brew made
his stylish solutions for everyone so
it's something that you put your wine in
keeps it cold keeps a cute looking there
are over 30 color options to choose from
including Matt glossy and glitter
finishes to match your drink of choice
style and personality oh I just say wine
but you can put any drink for if you do
sit well but like anyone's like up
there's literally like wine Kate like
bottles so you could put a wine a whole
wine bottle in Aleppo and then they also
have just a glassware so you can keep
your drinks cold in your cup like I saw
they were using like they were loose
fasting in plastic cups but they could
have used roommate I mean you know it
may be that what I've just like had
actually the trip did look fun the
drinks dude yeah I know it did the
drinks looked icy and watering right now
brew mate is giving our listeners a
special discount of 15% off your first
order when you go to WWE calm and use
our code toast that's 15% off when you
use our code toast at Burnett calm
don't let summer heat ruin your drink go
to brew mate calm and beat the heat this
summer get 15% off your first order by
using our code toast at brunette calm
that's be our um AEE calm code toast
highly recommend I just got mine and
it's so cute and pink and sparkly and
it's like I prefer to have that in a
picture than like a plastic ugly cup you
know who's really pissing me off this
episode Larsa Pippen she was being so
boring and like when they were all
getting turnt doin karaoke and Malika
and Khadijah were just like on their
hands and knees twerking she was just
like standing around like she's so lucky
to be there and like I feel like she
doesn't even care
yeah like I want to turn that party on
its [ __ ] nose you know and she like
really gets to be everywhere and I just
wonder what she brings to the table she
did seem like she was giving some good
advice good listener I guess yeah and
this Courtney storyline like I would
have rather have watched double the
amount of time of MJ and Scott then I
would have Courtney okay sorry am I
supposed to feel bad for someone who's
going through a breakup like it's very
normal you add to this boyfriend like
please you weren't even half as
devastated when you and Scott broke up
like this wasn't a real relationship
it's so such [ __ ] let go see bang
you know what like if you're
give me someone's like fake anxiety like
I've accepted Kendall's you know right
like the trial you know what I get it I
see it she seems very anxious but like
to be like I'm so anxious after the
spray no like that's not exactly that's
called just being dumb sad yeah no like
celebrities especially I feel like
Courtney like they use the a word
because they think it's like it excuses
everything it's for behavior yeah no
totally sees no effectiveness disorder
should I love her I can't eat it's just
like $300 escargot you know that was
funny
wait something really interesting that I
noticed this episode was Chloe and her
eating choices because they're always
just eating salads when they went to
dinner and Courtney was eating escargot
Chloe was eating spaghetti in the car
Chloe was eating a slice of pizza
interesting yeah and she's like this is
like the dinner she's ever been but the
first time I've seen her not eat salads
thankfully I was the only one who didn't
get into the pool and into a bathing
suit which um it's just something that I
noticed quite look so being a girl who
like never gets into the know being a
girl who often thinks about how
horrifying it would be to be in a
bathing suit on camera but I feel like
she's been in it it's like she's never
looked better she's been in the bathing
suit before I was just curious I was
like that windbreaker looks really hot
do you think it's weird that she calls
her baby mama about true ya know I mean
it's gonna be days that we call
I know it's just using precious gem of
man right right right
beautiful mats just like miss Leighton
lovely man um is it weird I call your
dog a man no he is a man what else true
is a mama I kind of feel bad for MJ
it's like Chris really moves her out
there to make Chris feel better like I
guess she had some guilt about her mom
being a few hours away and like not
visiting as much so she took advantage
of the when MJ was sick once and just
moved her [ __ ] house to like not even
a nice apartment I don't even know what
that was and I don't I feel bad for her
I feel bad for it too I love the
friendship between her and Scott I love
Scott I love his happiness and therefore
I love Sophia Richie because like she's
given us the best Scott that Scott can
be I totally agree and it's only been
together for so long now and they are so
legit I hope they get engaged and have
babies yeah but it's like I almost like
love also how Scott is thriving when
that Kourtney was obviously the one who
broke up with him and like Kourtney is
like flailing she was dating that really
ugly rapper yeah and I don't even think
they're still together but she was
rumored to be dating Justin Bieber like
there's just nothing more embarrassing
than that totally so I just like like he
won he came out on top when like she was
so mean to him for so many
the odds were stacked against him akia
at one point he legit had nothing and no
one and now he's made this really nice
life for himself where he's still
involved in the family and like the
sisters like him MJ like he'll never be
obvious yeah and he started a brand
called talentless cool it's a comfy
sweats oh yeah and they were in that
giveaway that Chloe did number like that
Louie Vuitton like that Kourtney did too
follow all these accounts Beca COO
friends weird clothing brand was in it
and talentless was in it too perfect I
hope it does well me I personally can't
afford to spend that on clothes and I'm
not gonna wear on the toast also it's a
great name yeah it is anyways I'm just
excited that Kardashian's his back but
like there was so much hype around it
and excitement and then you turn it on
and it's just like Courtney complaining
and I was like how did they fool us once
again
yeah it's a [ __ ] horse I just like
I'm Shane Courtney it's also crazy how
little Kylie films and Kendall - she was
like barely in this episode but Kendall
I feel like doesn't know him because
she's literally so uninteresting that
like there what could they fill him up
yeah
where's Kylie has the most interesting
life but I don't think she takes a
dollar from the show and just shows up
when she wants yeah which I'm happy for
her I wouldn't want to see her filming
and know that she doesn't want to be
there like when they're trying to beg
Kourtney to film do you feel like any of
the sisters are resentful that Kylie
doesn't film because like she's this
billionaire and and she has all of this
because of the show yes okay whatever
but like she grew up on the show she's
people know who she was because of the
show the show has always been the
backbone of their business and so she
reached a level and just decided not to
do it I don't think so because I think
for them they know that like she would
be so unhappy doing the show and then
they I think a lot of the sisters like
love do I think Khloe loves doing the
show I think she did so much her and I
think it's fun for her I think she's
naturally good at it I think good a lot
of hiding there are a lot of anxiety do
it so it's like why would I want to put
you in a situation it would be like if I
was asking snitch to co-host the toast
and she hated doing right I wouldn't I
wouldn't like be mad at her for not
doing it do you feel like part of
Khloe's good American deal cuz she
doesn't own good American I think
Nordstrom owns a good part of it that
other girl that she works with owns get
part of it and she does and I bet a lot
of her deal has to do with her running
on the show she was at the good American
shoot like I was just talking about it
oh yeah I'm sure it's good I don't think
it's part of her deal but I think rising
tide raises all ships and like she wants
go to marriage and to do well and
putting it on the show will help it do
well it does well everywhere it is
Hannah Angie is using a good American oh
it looks so corporate it looks like CA
dynasty it's not a good it's not a logo
I agree it doesn't show anything of what
the brand stands for it like it looks
like [ __ ] corporate we're going to
CES this year
did you watch I mean did you read the
New York Times article about the
Kardashians no it was all about just
like their money money money and like
all the different ways they make money
and the revenue streams but they did
address you know like Jameela Jamil is
like going in a hard on them for the
50/50 it was like apparently I've never
drank 15 but if you do it gives you like
crazy diarrhea I'm like that's how you
lose weight but they don't tell you that
so you just like drink it thing it's
gonna curb your appetite well next thing
you know you're like curled over a
toilet at least you're losing weight at
least he doesn't lie about that I guess
like right but so um thank you drinking
game they very directly the New York
Times like ask the Kardashians like if
they feel any sort of remorse like
taking money from this company that like
really is like not so healthy and they
were just like no that's so silly people
are always trying to come for us
they really don't give a [ __ ] yeah good
for them nor should they and like it's
not like they're the only people
advertising with the tea like take this
on with 15 do an American greed episode
about 15 a demo impressions if you're
not gonna come for like Emily
Ratajkowski and Bella Hadid for
promoting fire festival then why are you
coming Gregor dashians for promoting 15
I was watching um no I downloaded the
Daily Mail app just like to like browse
for stories and legit they had a
sponsored fit she ad like that's a huge
conglomerate I think the bigger question
is where are they getting all this money
very American greed makes you think who
send you in there I'm just always
looking for the next big scheme you know
okay what do you think it is oh [ __ ] I
feel like I've had a I feel like I've
had some good ideas but I actually do
think that some of these Instagram
brands like where they're getting their
money I feel like some of them couldn't
be definitely a friend like which ones
50 well I'm not gonna say 50 but so all
they so many any brand they're like
advertisers with the Kardashians like
that's so expensive yeah so if it's a
new brand like where did you just get
all this money how did your investors
just let you drop a million dollars who
else
advertises with them Oh sugar bear yeah
but sugar bear doesn't seem so fishy to
me
um I mean people say maybe like look
into fashion Nova but I think people
really shop there I think oh great
business I think it's like a very much
in the green mm-hmm and I heard Amber
Rose is a part owner in it they have
stores now like no they kill it and they
started with a partly winter yeah and
then every now and then they drop a mil
on Kylie yeah I I think that they're
very legit
yeah I don't know I'm just like oh wait
did you see that ultra turned into fire
festival yes oh my god I feel really
grateful that like I know that that
could never happen to me because I'm
like the antithesis of ultra I would
never go to ultra so I'm happy that it
could never happen to me but I feel bad
for all those people had to walk five
miles before but yeah treacherous
probably and really totally
I'm sure made it better I'd rather if
I'm gonna do that walking I'd rather be
like drunk and like having a good time
yeah dead sober and miserable so I'll
just like on an island I guess and they
had like a shuttle system yeah that was
just not good it was just not acquits
like usually out of festival everyone
leaves at the end so even if you have
buses that are going at 8 o'clock 9
o'clock at 10 o'clock your and I need
all the buses right so it just didn't
suffice and I guess they made it better
for something they said they were gonna
get it in place it wasn't totally fire
festival cuz at least there was a
festival it was like just people were a
little stranded um you know but it
happens at least like the walk was only
four miles it wasn't like yeah and like
how did the artists get back just fine
you know yeah well they had their own
cars right if you had a car as you can't
drive to Ultra no and the Ultra wasn't
letting ubers on the island in like that
was their policy cuz it would've been so
contorta like I mean the vessels are
like some of the most disorganized even
like the good ones and even Coachella
they have their [ __ ] together but it's
[ __ ] insane yeah it's like that that
neon carnival where you have to take
buses imagine if everyone left at the
same time and there weren't enough buses
no I will not be going but you know
they're doing any young carnival at
stagecoaches here yeah and that's just I
don't know why that sounds more fun it's
just of the people like the people I
coach I just can't believe we're gonna
meet those people
I know it's but we'll make it fun let me
get wrong yeah well always think you
know what like we said like if this is
the industry we want to be in like part
of that is Coachella
yeah and we very much like Ariana's
gonna be there we like to consider
ourselves the epicenter of all things
cool and Coachella unfortunately is cool
so we have to be there yeah yep yeah I
need to get close so our hotel event
like right now like are you leaving no I
mean like browse the Internet but um I
don't know what my ID is meet you you
know what I didn't order from Toby and
it was pretty good except I have to
return one thing and I can't figure it
out like if there's no label in the back
of it it was $80 like it's just 30 I
would be like okay it was 80 bucks and
like I want to [ __ ] return it yeah
but like I got a printer oh who has time
good luck my friend well thank you all
for tuning in yes I'm gonna be in oral
Joe in Clearwater Florida my last
Florida leg of this tour so head over to
girl my job to complicate your tickets
yes and we'll be back this week
celebrate until Santa Mercer see you
next week we have a really special guest
that we're filming a podcast only
episode with at the end of the week
oh really a podcast only yeah we're
going to her hotel it's like a whole
thing I'm shook and we're I will tell
you who it is soon I just like to insert
it right it's like so [ __ ] sad like
Joey King that happened to us right what
we announced I never heard from her
again
but that's I feel like we rarely have
announced things and every time that we
do it doesn't happen lady thing whatever
happened we just scheduling conflict
like I watch Colton on lady game last I
was it oh my god first of all they
actually might be more obsessed with him
than we are and they gave him the
respect that he deserves they were
treating him like a king like that and I
feel like he never gets treated that way
through that girls look you broke right
and they were just like having so much
respect for him and I thoroughly enjoyed
and he was like trying to talk sex and
like it was cute stop but and like they
didn't even call him out being like bro
you're a virgin until a month ago
I'd like love him but him Cassie's
ruining him him for me
I don't follow hit her on Instagram and
Margo keep sending me like stories like
cringy ones and it's really making it
hard for me to like stay in love with
him because I really love and respect to
him but like she's not good they're good
they're cute you have to remember
they're a little bit like younger than
us so they're just like being that's
what the kids do DC's and all I can
recommend is that you don't watch it
because it'll ruin them for you in like
I love them I don't want you I don't
want you to be like done with them just
don't watch it just ignore like just
look at the photo Margo to stop sending
so much of stories just look at the
photos like you couldn't deal with the
photos fine but the videos oh my god
they're such torture
okay above the money sorry the Millenial
morning show goes live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so thank you for hanging out
with us here if you're listening to this
as a podcast hello hope we sound nice we
are available as a podcast as well you
can find us anywhere podcasts can we
listen to Spotify iTunes everywhere else
thank you so much for listening to us
and I hope you have a wonderful day bye
you